hey hey it's a Luigi it's me Mario hey
OH
it matter yeah what are you doing yeah
Mario Mario centipede let's go get some
stars Luigi ya mean Luigi we got lock
this thing down yeah oh yeah let me do
it let me do it
hey Brad I don't like oh okay ah
alright you distract him breath and
al-saad you die okay
this is for my bear uh never mind
yeah get it again hey get the big the
only way you can revive me is if you get
that star and shove it to my butt all
right I'll do it for you Mario Luigi
wait you can run at the data what you
got are you speaking italian swedish to
me a brother no it's it only solo de
italiana I'm the big Baba lord of the
all black and matter I came back I just
jumped I just give it all the stuff we
catch a jump Luigi
I've got these fans oh yeah you're so
strong it must be all the beach balls Oh
started collected at Stowe
it's a Cheney just like my mom master
but no talk about mama batta like that
Mario turn around for me please scusa me
Mario come to me Luigi I am coming to
you clarify sweetie
all right I can't afford to knock you
off oh [ __ ] the dummy yeah oh [ __ ] em I
am in the middle and stop yeah yeah wait
it's it's simple I didn't [ __ ] look
that's why hey Luigi mama than me it's
impossible if I fail now I will cry the
tears of a mili
ah brother we're gonna pound this guy I
never understood what he actually you
just got a [ __ ] reg - I can smell his
spaghetti Saint it's spaghetti perfume
is here where is he
Mario all right digging your junk level
storm tower let's start power ok I'm
going there you go okay it's really late
I wish you not too fast I said that for
you I'm late to the sonic for a while
gotta go fast huh wait what am I going
out me off the level
Uchida okay alright I'll actually a
trial of last haha alright it's up to
the pewds you're playing to keyboard
yeah
not too bad for a keyboard yeah I got
skills
what do I owe they don't bread bread
that bra I did it for my brain stick
your face in here I slept through the
Bowser slap me slap my anus slap me slap
slap slap slap slap slap
oh hello no no no no no mommy actually
do it for camera angles there was
something you had to do here yeah I
remember how do you do it those mushroom
you fed me Mario way did they come with
the from I'm sure because right now it's
creeping my jor-el's of below toes the
lag I can't handle